if we talk in economic terms political
terms would be quite different in at
least the last two decades Peru has
become a benchmark for Latin American
countries with higher economic growth
rates and a lot of commercial openness
Peru has experienced a decrease in
poverty and has seen the middle class
grow throughout the country in recent
years however hold on a second because
this virtuous cycle of economic
prosperity it could be reaching its end
and not only that through all these
years although things are gone
reasonably well some problems haven't
been solved at all
for example Peru's huge dependence on
raw material back of diversification and
inability to join global production
chains
and all of this leads us to some
questions will prairie be able to
overcome these issues and emulate the
Asian Tigers come the country joined the
fourth Industrial Revolution and why on
earth haven't they yet managed to
overcome their dependence on raw
materials well we're gonna try and
answer these questions
in today's video but first we need to
take a look at the causes of Peru's take
off the foundations of the Peruvian push
so what has driven Peru's success in the
last 25 years this is a very brought in
question for Peru for the other Latin
American countries and practically
anyone who wants to seek their own
country escape poverty well to answer
this question we need to highlight two
major points
the first is orthodoxy and macroeconomic
stability and no don't worry it's not
boring at all see one of the keys to
Peru's growth is that its various
governments have opted for continuity
Nora Republica our hero really know
stories puesto la espalda amy police
near la democracia this means that the
country's political leaders have had
political differences just like everyone
else it's inevitable and good that they
also understand that there was a
development model a country model that
they couldn't touch Alberto Fujimori
Alejandro Toledo Alan Garcia in his
second term of course AIA honza Ramallah
Pedro Pablo Kaczynski and now Martin vez
kura six presidents with different
political approaches but basically the
same economic model it reminds me of the
Lord of the Rings but instead of the
ring there's an economic model one model
to rule them all the fact is that in the
last 25 years Peru has had its deficits
and public debt under control and they
have respected the central bank's
independence and avoided the temptation
to run the bill printing machine and
they've generally prompted investment
for example let's take a look at the
evolution of foreign investments in the
country see between 1980 and 1994 it
barely doubles but between 1994 and 2005
it multiplied by 4 and between 2005 and
today it's multiplying it by almost 7
that is to say foreign investment has
grown more and more in less time
[Music]
all that folks is cause Peru's growth
rates to average almost 6% per year for
more than 15 years check this out at an
APEC meeting they asked me what I
thought would happen to the Peruvian
economy in the international crisis and
I said that the only thing I was sure of
was that the country I was going to grow
the most this year was Peru Luis Alberto
Moreno president of the inter-american
Development Bank of course economic
growth ends up favouring almost everyone
in one way or another you don't have to
have a nobel prize in economics to
understand that one
[Music]
in Peru in less than 15 years a short
period of time the purchasing power per
capita almost doubles and poverty fell
by 30 percentage points
[Music]
but percentages are sometimes hard to
understand to really understand the
importance of such a reduction in
poverty we should talk about people
seven million Peruvians left poverty in
the last fifteen years thanks to the
country's economic growth
[Music]
but along with stability and
macroeconomic continuity the country's
other strategic commitments has been
opening up to foreign investments this
young Chi Yong Chi
I began in the 90s continued through the
turn of the century and it remains today
today Peru has free trade agreements
with no less than the three major
economic zones the United States China
and the European Union it's also part of
the Pacific Alliance and in general its
foreign policy is very much aimed at
achieving new trade agreements and all
this of course it certainly has its
consequences exports have increased from
three billion dollars in 1990 to more
than 52 billion dollars today in other
words they've multiplied by 17 but hold
on a second let's not bring the bells of
Success just yet these results they have
been fantastic that's certainly true but
now the model it seems just a bit
exhausted and yes you know we love
talking about good things and of course
Peru has many good things going for it
but guys like with Enron Blockbuster and
Nokia if we don't look at the other side
things don't end well indeed often they
will just hit you right in the face so
let's have a look at the main problems
that are preventing this country from
emulating the Tigers and the Dragons of
the Asian continent
[Music]
the peril that breaks Peru hasn't
escaped poverty yet despite its almost
25 years of uninterrupted growth the
country still has a lot of poverty worst
of all despite this growth in recent
years the Peruvian economy has been like
a balloon with an air leak that could
get a lot bigger allow me to explain
Peru continues to grow but its slowdown
is becoming more than evidence the
country is growing less and confidence
among businessman has decreased a lot
but that's not the worst part the worst
part is that the biggest changes they're
slow to arrive much sir than expected as
we've already mentioned there's still a
lot of poverty in the country and in
spite of all the growth it still doesn't
have a productive diversified and modern
economy essentially Peru continues to
depend on raw materials and now if its
growth slows down the question is well
how much longer is it gonna take for
things to change
we don't know but what we can try to do
is explain why it's so hard to make
changes in this country well here are
some ideas boom Dallas pugilist ilmu
Marisa primer gobierno de gracias de
yummy holla holla justice I shall not
see me cooperation fit the first problem
we're probably working to agree on this
one is that is political and it's got to
do with corruption
[Music]
have you heard about the Odebrecht case
well that's just the tip of the iceberg
the deal here is so dodgy that at least
five of the country's latest presidents
are suspected of being involved in cases
of corruption three are in jail for him
or ehim ala and Kaczynski and then
there's Alan Garcia Aaron's I'm sure you
already know his tragic and unfortunate
and Alan Garcia former federal president
dies after shooting himself before
arrest but this isn't the only political
mess in Peru parties get on so badly and
politics is so polarized and fragmented
that agreements are as difficult to
reach as say presidential candidacy
composed of Mauricio Macri and Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner well actually now
that we think about that one it wouldn't
be so hard to see
the fact is that of course this economic
polarization has stagnated the deep
facto economic reforms agenda since the
international crisis the country has
barely made any significant structural
reforms but some claim that the
government's in the Congress's lack of
productivity had a positive effect back
in the day the economic reforms of the
90s remained in place because of how
little the political class could get
done that is to say this immobile ISM
prevented politicians from changing the
country's economic course leading to the
aforementioned stability but of course
the problem is that time passes and
eventually changes are required
but that's all in the ends between their
corruption and their inability to reach
agreements Peruvian politicians have
turned Peru in suit the latin-american
country with the least confidence in
their political organizations in other
words Peruvians would trust vito
corleone or Darth Vader more than they
would their own politicians
[Music]
the second problem is that the
apparently good performance of the
country's economy has covered hidden and
camouflaged other issues which haven't
progressed well one of them is
productivity which hasn't only not
improved but since as far back as 1975
it's actually progressed negatively yep
yeah that right progressed negatively
it's a thing in the long term the net
result shows a secular stagnation in
Peru's productivity this is the main
cause of its lack of convergence of per
capita income with that of more advanced
economies Marta Reese runs idv advisor
now why is this important well folks to
look at it another way with data in
hands this means that a single American
worker is as productive as five Peruvian
workers and of course this comp be 70
years ago this figure wasn't five but
three an American worker was three times
more productive than a Peruvian worker
today though he or she is five times
more productive
[Music]
mind you this doesn't mean Peruvians
work less but that the jobs created in
the country have a very low added value
which generates very little and then of
course is due to structural problems
such as the inability to attract high
added value investments at lack of
competition a feeling of legal
insecurity a lack of entrepreneurship
infrastructure problems which are true
Ness cetera etc etc the surprised well
you shouldn't meet in fact it isn't the
only factor that has gotten worse this
is how Peru has evolved in the World
Competitiveness ranking
and this is important because one of
these secrets of the Asian economy is
that they began by specializing in
activities with little added value that
is so we can understand this better they
competed within low wages but at the
same time they always tried to improve
their level of competitiveness and you
can see this simply hasn't happened
improve this explains why traditional
exports the usual ones metals oils fish
milk represent more than 70% of all
Peruvian exports for example one of the
areas in which we can see the results of
this sluggishness is in education an
essential pillar for a country's
modernization
well after 25 years of strong economic
growth the peruvian education system it
continues to have more holes than a
wedge of swiss cheese according to the
IDB the inter-american Development Bank
only 30 percent of all educational
infrastructure can be considered
adequate anyway these are the main
problems that the country faces but just
hold on a second because Peru has done
many things well in recent years and we
can't end the video on such a negative
note so
[Music]
peddle progressive despite their
problems Peru has had one of the best
economic performances in Latin America
in the last three decades as we saw
earlier poverty levels dropped at full
speed and that's very good news also
between 2011 and 2070 in the middle
class went from nine million eight
hundred and forty seven thousand people
to almost 13.5 million this is a growth
amount of 40 percent in just five years
and although it has slowed down the
country is still the fastest growing
member of the Pacific Alliance
[Music]
anyway with this video we wanted to
explain why Peru is having a harder time
than expected in making the big leap but
now it's your turn do you think Peru
will finally manage to emulate the
success of the Asian Dragons well leave
your answer in the comments below and in
this survey and I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them as supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
I mean file is near la democracia
calorie shake allah-allah Liga choose
Disick Alice
this empty
put it in inaudible